Here's our first problem 20 pence cost
00 so how much a pen costs don't worry it is
not difficult to find the cost of a pen we
divide the total cost by 20 so the cost of a
pen is equal to 400 times 20 equals
₹ So many pen costs
₹ So this problem was very
simple If we are given the
total cost of many items we
divide the total cost by the number of items
to find the cost of one
item yr the next problem 20 pence costs
400 Find the cost  Of 30 pence If You
Think The Previous Problem Was Easy This One Should Also Seem Easy But That Is Not Always
The
Case One Student Doesn't See That They Have To Find Out
The Cost Of 30 Pence They Tend To Get
Confused We Found Out The Cost Of  1
pen to be 400 after 20 which is
₹ So think about it you have the cost of 1
pen What will be the cost of 30 pence It's
simple It will be 30 * after the cost of
1 pen so the cost of 30 pence is 30 *  ₹
Which Equals
₹ It Was As
Simple As That So 30 Pence Cost
00 Let's Analyze What We Just Did We Were
Given The Cost Of A Set Of Pence And We Were Asked
To Find The Cost Of Another Set Of
Pence If We Are Given The Total  Cost of 20
pence We've been asked to find the cost of
pence To find the total cost of 30 pence We
first found out the cost of nine pens using this
information and then we
found the cost of 30 pence by
multiplying the cost of one  Pen with
30 This method of finding the cost of one
unit first and then multiplying by the
number of units to find the total cost is called the unitary method
Remember cost of one unit first
and then the total cost according to there
is another interesting way
in which  We can look at it
the question says that 20 pence costs
00 so how much does 30 pence cost cost of
30 pence is given s 400 m 30 / 20 wow we
use just one step we just multiply those
two terms and divide this product by
Term There are two ways in which you can
understand this first we were actually
dividing 400 by 20 to get the cost of one
unit and directly multiplying this
by 30 to find the total cost of 30
units so what we did using two
steps previously is done in  One Step Year This gives
as the cost of one unit and its
product with 30 gives as the total
cost of 30
units second 400 by 20 will always equal
total cost of 30 pence by 30 This is obvious
since each ratio is equal to the cost
Of one pen as this is proportion product
of extremes should equal the product of
means so 400 m 30 should equal 20 m ba cost
of 30 pence and then we transpose 20 to the
other side to get the cost of 30
pence anyway this was just for  Your Better
Understanding So 20 m 20 e 400 and 20 m ba
30 e
00 both methods are
essentially the same it's just that we have solved this one in one step instead of two this
is also called the
unitary method so if we have to generalize it
We can say that if a items cost r b then
c items will cost b ba a m ba c b ba
a is the cost of one item and c is the total
number of
[music]
items